[Music]
has anybody here ever been on one of
those like carnival cruises yeah yeah we
went on a princess cruise it's a company
it was for old people yeah wow that's
all cruises my friends we did not well
this one was very old people we were the
only young we did not [ __ ] realize it
until we got there
when we went to the club though the old
people were partying like yeah because
we were the only young people so they're
like those youngins look like they're
having a great time we're gonna go and
socialize with them
it was a geriatric thing yeah dude
there's one guy who sang the same my way
like like i think it's frank sinatra
song like every [ __ ] night yeah every
my favorite experience from that the jk
cruise was um so we were like hang out
as a group and then we would like break
off and do like couple stuff and then
we'd meet up at night one of our
couple's things me and gio decided to
get like a couple's like hot stone
massage but you know like the cruise
falling off yeah the crew the boat kind
of rocks you know like the night before
me and dave were playing basketball and
you would literally shoot and you would
see the post like go like that
that's hilarious so me and joe get hot
stone massage like this and then they
put like the hot oil and [ __ ] on their
backs and then she'd put the hot stones
and it feels good but then when the boat
would move it would just fall
[Laughter]
on the bed like like a laughing
you just kept sliding and falling
i swear to god they played um they were
supposed to be relaxing
they played like ymca five times a day
because the old folks love ymca and when
went off though like that was everybody
they threw their walkers just so they
could [ __ ]
every time it went off it was like
remember the kid that kept drowning in
the pool
what oh there's this pool on the deck
right and then so as the boat's rocking
all the water goes down to one side so
there's this kid with his grandpa
the kids there the water comes and you
see the kid go oh [ __ ] the water's
coming and the grandpa's on this side so
he's just up here like i need to save
you i can't and then the cart's coming
back this way but he's tall enough to
get out of the pool so when the water
comes this way he stands up and now the
kid's up here and he's trying to get him
and as soon as he's tries to get some it
rocks the other way and you just see
this kid getting
[Laughter]
unfortunately we cannot interfere nature
will take course if the poors are to die
than they are to die
i don't want to mess with the tides you
know
so there's a carnival cruise recently
that's what we should have done
because it's younger that's what i did
dude it's it's trash too bro it's the
same [ __ ]
by the way it should all be free would
you rather would you rather be with
geriatric trash or a youthful track i
was with it was a bothy because like
you're with poor people so it was like
us
it was us you know like because we hit
we were like it was like a very cheap
cruise like deal yeah like on the back
of a soda can
oh [ __ ] we're not too insane go to a
cruise baby for twenty five dollars it's
like that so yeah you went to the uh
tijuana not tijuana yeah
yeah that's how it is
i had a pretty good time did you guys
have a pizza bar like 24 hours yeah yeah
that was one of the best things there
the pizza's awful i like it yeah but if
you stay drunk the whole time
okay i didn't knock on a boat three days
later like this piece is kind of good
well that's the other thing is boats in
me i don't think we get along very good
you get c6 i had needed the drama mean i
didn't have it yeah i got [ __ ]
seasick surprise they didn't have any on
boat to sell you because that's how they
get you oh really that's not like they
want you to stay sick that's what they
do they they want you to buy the
drowning oh yeah
like like
that [ __ ] on [ __ ] purple yeah
it's just docked
it's just a simulator he has a rocking
bar you can rock the whole boat with
get to the pool again i'm gonna get to
this article now uh there's a there's a
carnival cruise um that had a giant
brawl on it recently nice
that involved 60 people 60 people
[Laughter]
it lasted for so long that they needed
the u.s coast guard to come out and come
out to help dock the ship
the [ __ ] up it all started allegedly
because there was a threesome that took
place and somebody got caught uh that
would elicit some strong emotions how
does that make me want to fight you
though five floors five floors because
i'm picturing um you know those european
like soccer games yeah oh
like two logs yeah hooligan style yeah
i'm picturing like an old western
because bar bro
brawl where like one person [ __ ] we
have a video and he goes down maybe
maybe a little bit of a video ducking
because if somebody ducked you could
accidentally hit together
yeah see that's what always happened i
would i would also assume though again i
don't i don't really know
i'm also assuming that there's like uh
there's like when people come they come
in like giant groups right because when
you do like a tour or like a carnival
cruise or something like that you go
with like a large group of friends you
might have like 20 friends on a trip but
then there might also be another group
of like 20 plus friends on another trip
and then yes i think if beer bottles are
like flying and somebody's ducking you
know what i mean it's not really about
some with my brother who's getting hit
with a chair for sure
uh girl
this is yeah but this is just a 30
second clip of actual brawl time
you can kind of see
looks like a party
oh no oh
this is happening in the club
in
the dance floor
look at this dude
the security is i ain't trying to break
up 200 people
you kind of got to let them duke it out
a little bit huh well it's just their
system
i think that's what they were doing but
it just kind of kept on going you know
what i mean more people kind of getting
involved and it started going into like
multiple floors and stuff like that this
car needed to get involved that's crazy
yeah i know they have like briggs and
most ships so if you get like rowdy or
whatever they can like lock you up but i
imagine there's not enough space on this
ship to like oh they do yeah like if
you're like they need to like arrest you
on the boat they have like bricks and
there's a cruise jail damn i didn't even
think about that yeah well they lock you
in your room one of the two that's what
happened to leo dicaprio on titanic
mm-hmm that's what happened i don't even
remember i don't remember that you don't
watch titanic did they have free pizza
on the titanic
they should they did if you were on the
upper decks yeah that's what i heard i
don't even know if they had pizza
come on they had pizza of course they
had pizza it's a cruise it's a cruise
and free ice cream yeah ice cream i had
a guy doing my way every day
had a guy doing my life
that was like his song
and he was so happy every time he sang
it too he was just like we
that's got to be his thing though that's
probably like he probably
does like he's literally doing it his
way [ __ ]
he's literally doing it
he was living out his dream i guess
he's a crooner
so there's there's no way you guys would
go on a cruise not anymore no way after
that experience yeah my my in-laws want
to do like a mediterranean one or or
what's the one where it's kind of cool
go to greece and like you go to a
[ __ ] school
my mom was going to do one where she
starts from ireland and goes all the way
through like the mediterranean where
it's like greece all those places and
it's like a whole [ __ ] month yeah
that's what my in-laws want to do
or maybe it's one of those things where
like 20 years from now when we're like
significantly older we're gonna love
them because everybody's gonna be our
age yeah
dude
you think in 20 years you just wake up
on your birthday and you're like
holy [ __ ] ymca's playing holy [ __ ]
every year on your birthday you just
have nikki play that song like alright
we're good for another year i think
we're good right now yeah
i was like this is kind of fire
that song does always
it bumps nikki's picking up some gaudy
ass jewelry she's like oh i think this
is starting to look good
that's when it's gonna get scary you got
to put on your teeth and [ __ ] i i'm down
her hair just naturally starts perving
like for no right
immediately
hmm i think it would depend if i start
getting more seasick or not you know
some people like grow into their
seasickness or they grow out of it
really yeah i'm like right at the i
think i'm right at the phase where it's
like
i can go out probably for a day or two
it's fine but then spending like four
days on the the ship that'll [ __ ] you up
when i came off of it i had like sea
legs for like the whole week damn what
was squatting like
dude it was weird
that was the weirdest part i'm like
eating at a [ __ ] restaurant and it
just feels like the whole restaurant
still and i'm like at jj cafe i'm like
what the [ __ ]
i'm like what the [ __ ] man you're
[ __ ] trying to eat your noodles like
this
hey guys you drunk go home
i remember getting back on land and
being like i'm never going on a [ __ ]
boat again
did you throw up on the boat oh yeah we
threw up we threw up all over our
[ __ ] room me and nicky both
you guys all get seasick
yeah i don't i don't i get seasickness
yeah i mean i can
uh like if it's like really intense
conditions you know what i mean but
other than that it's not
i don't get seasick but i feel it it
does it's not like oh this is the same
as being still yeah yeah like it's like
just potentially excuse me like this
yeah i think i could talk myself into
being seasick like really why the [ __ ]
would you do that what if it's like you
know you could like talk you could just
you would just willpower yourself to
throwing up you're just like doing kind
of sick and then like talk yourself into
it you know what i mean you none of you
guys do that you're a strange man i do
that i want to see nick juggling on a
cruise being [ __ ] pissed having a
juggle i want to see a pick into a fight
with a jungler on the crew oh yeah
[ __ ] you man hey [ __ ] your whole life
you must have passed college
[Laughter]
steve goes and fights the magician i
will beat up a magician
dude
you know those cruise ships they always
have a [ __ ] magician they always have
entertainment
they have a clean comedy
style yeah yeah but it's kind of funny
love it and they always have loveboat
playing on on in the room they're sneaky
though those magicians you got to get
the blanket before they get to the
blanket because if they get to the
blanket before you get to them because
you're going to [ __ ] throw blows
right yeah the blanket and then they
drop it they're
gone do you want to fight a magician and
you're convinced that magic is real as
well they're just like these [ __ ]
wizards i gotta stop they're no they're
tricky
you're if you get the blanket first then
you go off the bike he's like oh [ __ ] i
don't know the [ __ ] blanket
always get the blanket first if you're
going to beat a magician no
he's going to disagree
he's gone that son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you